voici le seul cimetière musulman du
québec unique au pays avec sa clôture
qui sépare les défunts chiites et
sunnites
depuis son ouverture en 1993 entre une
voie ferrée et un pipeline les musulmans
ils sont enterrés selon le rituel
religieux et dans des tombes orienté
vers la mecque
mais la communauté musulmane québécoise
s'est agrandi d'ici cinq ans il n'y aura
plus de classes ici
c'est ce que prévoit mazen mograbi il a
été mandaté par les mosquées de brossard
et de saint-hubert pour acheter un
terrain et ouvrir un nouveau cimetière
musulman
cela permettrait du même coup d'amasser
des fonds pour les activités de l'école
apprendre le coran aux enfers rené les
enfants solvimo besoins de la mosquée de
l'entretien cerveau jusqu'à former un
homme depuis plus de deux ans l'agent
immobilier claude huart cherche un
terrain propice dans un vaste périmètre
au sud de montréal pour la muslim
welfare association qui chapeaute les
deux mosquées il a approché une
quinzaine de municipalités multiplier
les offres d'achat sans succès les
démarches ont toujours un peu avortée
par ce que il semble que les
municipalités refusent systématiquement
pourtant à huntingdon en 2013
le maire de l'époque voulait ce projet
de cimetière il était prêt à vendre un
terrain de la ville
alors vous voyez le terrain prévu
c'était vraiment l'autre côté de la
ligne d'arbre ici on avait mis une ou
qu'ils devaient servir aussi maintien
avec le chemin d'accès qui pensez y si
on tournait à gauche et ça se faisait le
tout simplement oui un terrain enclavé
qui servait absolument à venir qui
rapportaient rien à l'avenir rapporte
absolument rien la vie stéphane gendron
et voyait un moteur de développement
économique
j'ai toujours cru en moi que
l'immigration maghrébine en particulier
est une immigration instruite qui
s'intègre facilement sur un plus pour
une ville de huntingdon qui qui était
d'éviter lisez nos camarades feu mais le
projet s'est buté à l'opposition de
quatre conseillers municipaux sur six
c'était pouvant table les choses que
j'ai entendu derrière les portes closes
et même publiquement pendant les séances
du conseil
je sais même pas 16 10 ans non parce que
je veux pas encourager davantage
l'islamophobie et le racisme
mais le refus n'était basé que sur des
préjugés raciaux et religieux
l'agent immobilier renchérit avec
l'exemple de hinchinbrooke là non plus
les conseillers n'ont pas voulu ils se
sont dépêchés de voter un règlement qui
empêchait la municipalité de donner des
services dedans funéraires ou dans terme
à des personnes qui sont qui qui
proviennent de l'extérieur de leur
communauté
hajir à belkacem vient de fonder
l'association pour la sépulture
musulmane elle ne tient pas un deuxième
cimetière réservé aux musulmans
elle préfère l'idée très française de
carré musulman d'un cimetière existant
je pense qu'une bon show de chercher
donc des cimetières existence à ce qu
une très bonne chose
ça démontre notre notre intégration
notre volonté de
de vivre ensemble et de mourir ensemble
aussi comme la majorité des membres de
sa communauté elle ne fréquente pas les
mosquées
elle ne tient pas à les enrichir
d'autant plus que l'argent recueilli à
laval ne semble pas avoir permis de bien
entretenir le cimetière musulman
elle n'est pas conforme il n'est pas
adéquat c'est pas comme ça qu'on
comptait un moment il est mal gérée et
lire tout à fait abandonné son
association a signé une entente avec une
entreprise funéraire qui lui permettra
de traiter les dépouiller de les
enterrer en respectant le rituel
musulman
mazel mograbi ou six a conclu un contrat
avec un cimetière de la rive sud
faute de mieux on l'a déjà pris comme un
système d on a un contrat avec les
autres pour régler les situations mais
ça ne rapporte pas le premier de choses
l'argent quand ça peut nous rapporter
sur nos propres soutiens pour le porte
parole des mosquées de saint-hubert et
de brossard ce n'est pas juste une
question d'argent c'est aussi une
question de principe nous compter ceux
des canadiens et des québécois
puis c'est au dp ya des tacles mais ont
le droit de choisir la place pouchkine
s'enterrer avec toutes ces années vécues
le premier ministre couillard disait
récemment qu il voulait établir des
liens avec la communauté musulmane mais
lorsqu'on arrive à des problèmes
concrets comme chez lui l'eau personne
ne veut mettre ses culottes puis prendre
la responsabilité de dire il faut
s'occuper de ce dossier deux ou non du
premier ministre accuse réception du
courriel
il y a deux mois et demi plots du hac
s'est adressé au premier ministre
couillard dans l'espoir qu'il dénonce ce
qu'il qualifie d' impasse
mais québec refuse d'intervenir
le gouvernement promet une nouvelle
politique d'intégration qui va
privilégie la neutralité de l'état
donc pas question d'intercéder en faveur
d'une communauté religieuse pour
l'implantation d'un cimetière